and despite clear signs that the
american people do not want a hot war
with russia the bide administration
almost seems hell-bent on frightening us
into one now the latest salvo started
sunday with secretary of state lincoln's
big promise
if for instance the polish government a
nato member wants to send fighter jets
does that get a green light from the u.s
are you afraid that that will escalate
tension
no that that that gets a green light in
fact we're talking uh with our polish
friends right now about what we might be
able to do to backfill
their needs well
not convinced that that was a brilliant
idea well neither were some of lincoln's
friends at the pentagon spokesman john
kirby earlier today clarified that the
u.s did not support transferring fighter
planes from nato bases in germany to
ukraine
but have no fear the deep state
spinsters were on capitol hill today
intent on making you feel
like we have to do a lot more
our analysts assess that putin is
unlikely to be deterred by such setbacks
and instead may escalate essentially
doubling down to achieve ukrainian
disarmament and i think putin is angry
and frustrated right now he's likely to
double down and try to grind down the
ukrainian military with no regard for
civilian casualties
joining me now former democrat
congresswoman tulsi gabbard um
congresswoman
why are we talking about no-fly zones
instead of the fact that for the first
time
we have president zielinski stepping
back
from his earlier nato wishes and even
demands
that that is literally the most
important question here laura you know
when i look at these issues i think
about what is in the best interest of
the american people is what we're doing
going to be good for the american people
or not and clearly this continued
escalation of this conflict and this war
is not in the best interest of the
american people or the world frankly
which is why zielinski's statement last
night with on on abc news for the first
time
that i'm aware of opening the door a
window of opportunity where he's open to
the fact of saying hey yeah maybe maybe
we'll set this nato membership thing
aside and he's willing to talk with
putin directly to negotiate uh the
outcome or the status of these disputed
territories really extending an olive
branch
two points here the first thing i
thought is why isn't this making
headlines everywhere
why isn't everybody talking about this
uh even abc news themselves didn't write
a great piece and publish this across
all their platforms had to dig to find
it but secondly and and really most
importantly is
why isn't the biden harris
administration
charging forward to take advantage of
and support president zielinski in in
this opening that that he has created in
trying to bring about an end to this
conflict bringing about an end to this
suffering that we're seeing every single
day
now is the only conclusion
isn't it the case excuse me for
interrupting but isn't it the case that
the longer
this goes on
unless there's some miracle in the
offing but the longer this goes on
the higher the price
i would argue that putin's going to try
to enact
from ukraine it's not like it's going to
get easier as time goes on it's going to
get harder
for ukraine as it gets goes on and yet
yeah we don't seem to hear any of this
any discussion of this
from the foreign policy elites in
washington
nothing that the biden administration
has done has helped to make this
situation better has helped to
de-escalate the situation which is why
the only conclusion that i can draw
about why they have been completely
silent and not engaging at all on this
window of opportunity that president
zielinski opened last night is that what
is happening before our eyes right now
is exactly what they
want to see
continue
why is that because it's good for the
the military-industrial complex it makes
these politicians uh look tough and and
really you know it allows them to have
this proxy war with russia something
that hillary clinton laid out just
recently really what their aims are this
this war machine this power elite in
washington is they want to turn ukraine
into another afghanistan turn into
killing fields where this long-term
insurgency is supported and they bleed
out and and uh kill as many
russians as possible for who knows who
knows how long and and they're really
showing their real aim in the fact that
they're not taking action right now to
end this conflict now it might not
surprise you since you just mentioned it
but hillary clinton is indeed
back on the war wagon watch
if you care about freedom if you care
about democracy if you care about
the rights of
individuals
if you care about our future even though
it's a war that is happening
uh far away it is a war that will affect
um what kind of world we're going to
live in the ukrainians are really
and i would argue fighting for all of us
tulsi so they're fighting for americans
in
ukraine what who who's
people like hillary clinton and joe
biden camellaris they all use this
flowery language about how you know
we've got to take a stand and pay the
price the american people need to pay
you know so much more for gas so much
more for food make those decisions
between filling their gas tank and
buying groceries because
freedom
the question that we should all be
asking them is okay
tell us how
russia somehow has the power to take
away our freedom of speech here in
america tell us how russia has the power
to take away
the the freedom and rights of parents
who want to
make sure their kids are getting a
quality education uh tell us how russia
has the power somehow to take away our
right to bear arms the rights that are
enshrined in our bill of rights the
answer to these is they don't
they don't have that power so the the
lines that were being sold it's just
crap laura it's crap and sadly their
actions are resulting in more and more
people suffering rather than being
leaders and de-escalating this and
bringing about an end to this war now we
have our own politicians eroding our
constitutional rights every day and we
see it on the supreme court as well
tulsi great to see you tonight as always
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else